the system is broken i'm a gp my husband
is a gp
we weren't able to access a test via the
normal routes and we had to cheat the
system
claire silito voices the frustration of
many
a sick child with suspected covet but no
way of getting a test
i must have refreshed that screen 100
times i checked all night
2 a.m 4 a.m i checked again all day
sunday
and again there was absolutely no test
sites available
and then what did you do so on monday
in desperation because i'd already
missed a whole clinic of seeing patients
i then went to a local test centre and
just
begged and said that i'm a local doctor
i really need to have a test to enable
me to see patients face to face
um and they were lovely they they helped
me to manage to to get a qr code by
using a postcode in scotland
why are people still struggling to get a
test infections are rising capacity is
falling the issue
at the top of today's cabinet meeting
the health secretary then called to the
commons
to explain he says it'll take weeks to
manage demand
there are operational challenges and
we're working hard to fix them
there's demand as risen so we're having
to prioritize once again
and i do not shirk from decisions about
prioritization
they're not always comfortable but they
are important
the top priority is and always has been
acute clinical care
the next priority is social care
kierstama himself
isolating accused the government of not
planning
for a predictable rise in demand what
it's doing is
promising for tomorrow and failing to
deliver for today
um what i say to the government is focus
on the problem you've got
there's obviously a problem with the
system except it's a problem and do
something about it
many will agree with kiss armour schools
colleges and universities returning
alongside many workers
was bound to spread the infection
leading to a rise in cases
matt hancock says there are some
operational challenges
but won't say exactly what these are and
we know that dr
silito did manage to get a test and a
result
so there must be at least some capacity
in the system and one lab we've spoken
to says it's carrying out
tens of thousands of tests every day
so where exactly is the problem
it may lie with the government strategy
to cope with its testing workload
it asks university staff to help in its
newly established
lighthouse labs a network of public and
private labs
but some of these specialists were only
contracted for six months
boris johnson asked for them to return
but warned
even more specialists would be needed in
his letter addressed to leaders of
universities the prime minister says
we need over 400 people to add to your
workforces
in these laboratories the issue at the
moment is the capacity within the
lighthouse labs that has
fallen quite suddenly and um that's we
think due to a loss of staff
uh the staff that were employed in in
this
in the lighthouse labs at the beginning
of this were largely came from
uh academic institutions and then
they're returning to the
job they started so they've now been
back as universities
from normal life the government says
it is making sure critical workers like
dr silito
will be able to get tested they are a
priority
but that could be some weeks off the
need
is now ashish joshi sky news